all right everybody ready just stretch
him out this is a hatchling this is a
brand-new snake this was born this year
this is maybe a month old within five
years this will be 1213 feet
it's amazing how quick they grow
the swamp Apes take veterans into the
Everglades to track and capture Burmese
pythons we help the veterans overcome
their challenges from their service at
the same time the wilderness benefits
from the removal of these animals my
name is Tom Rae Hill I founded the swamp
apes the swamp apes are an organization
dedicated to serving veterans who serve
in the wilderness the Everglades is
renowned for its biological diversity
it's under threat by the Burmese pythons
the Burmese pythons have decimated the
mammal population that's their primary
food source it's estimated that there
are over a hundred thousand pythons in
the Everglades the swamp apes have
captured and removed over 1,000 pythons
the Burmese pythons largely were
released by irresponsible pet owners a
15-foot Python could have 60 hatches and
it's just it's an exponential problem
the hope is to remove enough of the
breeding females that we can severely
diminish the population
during the wet season which we're in now
the technique for capturing pythons is
road cruising at night when it's a
little moist out reptiles come out onto
the road we have a policy of live
capture with the pythons we effectively
jump on the pythons
you grab them as soon as you can behind
the head that business end of a Python
can be very dangerous we turn them over
to the scientists sadly 99% of these
animals have to be euthanized that's a
whole population and native critters
that are being saved the swamp base
began in 2008 for me as a tool to deal
with some personal grief when my wife
moved to Arkansas to take a teaching job
I'd only see her once every month or two
consequently I was hurting emotionally
and I went and started volunteering in
the Everglades National Park I then was
invited to join the Python eradication
team and at a certain point it occurred
to me that this would be great for
veterans also with PTSD and other
challenges
the swamp apes are a unique program we
embrace the veterans skill set basic
training for a veteran would include
situational awareness threat assessment
self-reliance chain of command mission
focus of your mojo working once they get
out of the service they don't
necessarily have a place to apply the
basic training let alone specialized
training swamp apes use that training
and celebrate that training and the
veterans service by applying it to
Python removal one for me good money we
had positively impacted hundreds of
veterans with the program they benefit
from the natural therapy of being out
there tracking capturing and removing
the pythons pretty girl our ultimate
goal is to have therapists accompany us
and be a prescribed herbal therapy
organization as noble and as effective
as the swamp apes are in engaging
veterans at the end of the day we get to
jump on big snakes it's awesome
[Music]